occupied land failed peace talks a
one-state solution if you think I'm
talking about Israel Palestine nope
actually I'm talking about Cyprus well
even though it's a small Mediterranean
island it kind of has the future of the
European Union on its back here's the
thing
Cyprus is split in half by UN buffer
zone the south is the internationally
recognized Republic of Cyprus and the
north
that's a self-proclaimed Turkish
Republic of Northern Cyprus by itself
for claimed I mean it's not officially
recognized as a country by the United
Nations it actually declared its
independence from Cyprus in the 1980s
and Turkey is the only country to
officially recognize it hey guys I'm
Sunna this is a j+ and we're going to
tell you a little story about how Cyprus
got divided and why it could actually
determine the future of the European
Union so why does Cyprus come to be
divided and why does it hold so much
influence in the --use future well
before getting into why it holds that
influence let's talk a little bit about
how it even got here in the 1950s a
right-wing greek cypriot of guerrilla
organization called yoga started an
armed struggle against the British
colonialists they wanted the island of
Cyprus to become part of Greece and they
had a lot of popular support but the
minority Turkish Cypriot population
wasn't really down with that they were
more aligned with the British so they
started pushing for a partition
splitting the island into two with
Turkey taking one-half and Greece taking
the other in the end the British decided
on kind of a compromise Cyprus became a
unified independent island nation in
1960 and the British wrote a
constitution ensuring that both Greek
and Turkish Cypriots shared power in the
government they also gave themselves
along with Turkey and Greece guarantor
powers a special status that meant they
were supposed to protect Cyprus and keep
an independent but tensions between the
Greek and Turkish Cypriots had reached a
breaking point inter-communal fighting
broke out in 1963 and Turkish Cypriots
started moving into their own enclaves
there was also a political deadlock as
both sides that veto to each other in
Parliament and eventually Turkish
Cypriot politicians resigned from the
government altogether the fighting
continued for over a decade
in 1974 things went from bad to worse
the military junta in Greece launched a
coup in Cyprus out sting the president
it only lasted a couple of weeks but
that was enough for Turkey based on the
claim
they were invoking their right as a
guarantor they intervene militarily and
seized over a third of the island the
Greek Cypriots however fought back
in fact the fighting lasted a month and
in the aftermath a UN controlled buffer
zone or green line was established
dividing the island the North declared
itself the Turkish Republic of Northern
Cyprus while the South remained the
Republic of Cyprus over a decade more
than 2,000 Greek and Turkish Cypriots
went missing and the island till this
day remains divided now that's a lot of
history a lot of messy history but how
does that history translate into it
impacting the future of the European
Union
well Turkey's been trying to get into
the EU for a minute now but negotiations
haven't actually gotten very far a major
reason for that is well you guessed it
cyprus cyprus is an EU member state and
when a country like turkey wants to join
cyprus has veto power every step of the
way and cyprus has been using it one
reason they're vetoing turkey is you
know that whole military intervention
thing to this day turkey maintains
30,000 troops in Turkish occupied
Northern Cyprus and the south isn't
really cool with that and another reason
turkey doesn't recognize the Republic of
Cyprus as a legitimate country let alone
a member state of the EU so it sounds
like Turkey's EU bid is dead in the
water right well if Cyprus and Turkish
occupied Northern Cyprus work things out
it might not be the latest round of
negotiations between the two sides began
in 2014 and if that happens Turkey might
recognize Cyprus as a legitimate country
Cypriots on both side of the Green Line
sent to gain a lot from reunification
but decades of conflict and a tug and
pull of power has left life for Cypriots
in the north and south freedom
difference because of trade sanctions
and embargoes on its ports and airports
Northern Cyprus is kind of like the cube
of the Mediterranean it's politically
and economically isolated from the rest
of the world and its economy is stifled
in fact you can't fly anywhere from the
north except for Turkey and it's totally
reliant on Turkey for trade exports and
eight the south on the other hand is
currently in much better shape they've
enjoyed the benefits of trade with the
EU for over a decade now since 2004 and
they adopted the euro currency in 2008
but lots of Greek Cypriots lost their
homes during the conflict and now
they're pushing for
that would allow some of them to return
or at least receive compensation take
for example for OSHA this neighborhood
and famagusta was once home to nearly
40,000 greek cypriots but they were
forced out by Turkish troops now a ghost
town held when Northern Cyprus as a
bargaining chip in negotiations
according to one estimate a total of 165
thousand Greek Cypriots or displaced
from Northern Cyprus during the conflict
or around 40% of the population at the
time so where does Cyprus go from here
the latest round of un broker talks have
been called cypresses best chance yet at
a reunification the goal of the recent
talks is to establish one unified
country with a single citizenship while
recognizing the independent nature of
the north and south but not everyone is
optimistic the island voted in a 2005
referendum and while Turkish Cypriots
voted for the deal Greek Cypriots shut
it down and today there are still
obstacles in the way of reunification
but both parts of Cyprus are led by
leaders who want unity and that's
brought the hope that the future of a
united Cyprus is actually closer than
many may think so one of the things that
I learned while helping make this video
was that it's pronounced Cypriots not
superyachts what about you what did you
guys learn let us know in the comments
and don't forget to Like and subscribe
and share the video